e
oh wow that's loud holy crap uh good
morning everybody uh representative
Maguire is not going to be here today so
I'll be chairing the meeting today um
we'll get an open meeting with the
Pledge of Allegiance sen the ward would
ledge I
ofice thank you sen of the
Lord next up is um approval of the
minutes entertain a motion to approve
the minutes as presented moved it's been
moved by representative Lyn second by
representative gr how do you say last
Jackie I'm sorry
um uh Mr chair could we uh set altern
alternates for the Mee sure who do we
so uh representative hacken Phillips
will sit in for representative Schmidt
and representative grassy will sit in
for chair
Maguire
okay
that's she's a regular member y
so I think we're all set perfect ready
all right I'm sorry so again we have a
motion on the floor by representative
Lyn second my represent R to approve the
minutes is there any discussion on the
minutes hearing none all those in favor
signifi by saying I all opposed name
eyes have it the minutes are adopted
um next up is the consent calendar or
any items wishing to come off the
seeing none uh I accept a motion to
approve the consent to calendar don't
move second moved by representative Liv
second by sen leward to approve the
consent calendar as presented all those
in favor signified by saying I I all
those oppos n the eyes have a consent
calendar is adopted moving on to the
regular calendar item number three first
up is the Department of Health and Human
Services um uh FP 23 1994 the
immunization
registry uh so the agency did file a
conditional approval request that did
address all of the comments on the final
proposal however in reviewing the
conditional approval it was noticed that
there was one word missing on the
acknowledgement on the form that's in
the rule text um I have talked with the
agency I believe they're going to
request an oral CA to include that word
in the form
um and should they do that I would
recommend that this be approved uh
conditionally approved with that oral
Amendment good morning Allison radme uh
administrator of the administrative
rules unit at the Department of Health
and Human Services um we are in
agreement that um we will be making a
change to um mirror the rule text in the
form language um however we do ask that
we flip-flop that and we're actually
going to remove the word immunization
from the rule um and keep the form as is
so where where exactly in the rule is a
change we're asking for so anybody wants
to follow along oh I apologize it's on
our conditional approval request on page
seven and it's the first paragraph at
the
top thank you so that sentence will read
received immunization as requested to
request withdrawal of information from
the state
territory further discussion
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you both
for being here um as I was reviewing
this rule I noticed that none of the
information about um how we handle
withdrawals relative to other states was
included that had been in earlier
working drafts um we had put to get put
I had put forward legislation in
parallel with the Department's intention
to handle withdrawals from outof State
immunization systems um consistent with
our constitutional protections for right
to privacy
that had moved forward but it was
interim studied in the Senate because
they thought that it was unnecessary
because it would be included in rules
yet reviewing for the meeting today
those important protections were removed
and it was reversed in policy and I'm
curious I I'd like to understand why
made good morning Emory mcum the
immunization section chief um that was
changed because we um felt like it was
premature to go ahead and change the
administrative rules in the response to
the legislative session which did not
enact that legislation um it did go to
interim study we would be required to
follow um any statutory change that does
come down and and from that um interim
study um we would also be doing our due
diligence first of all the IM
immunization information system is a
voluntary system so as part of the
consent for a person to share share
their information they would be provided
the information that their information
may be shared with another state if they
received medical care or immunization in
that state and um the patient if they
chose to um go ahead and participate in
our program they would uh and later
change their mind they would be able to
seek New Hampshire withdrawal and they
would also be able to seek withdrawal
through that other state directly um the
problem with the legislation was the
involvement of the department on the
onus of who was performing that
withdrawal um was it the Department's
requirement to do the withdrawal or was
it the individual person who may have
received vaccinations in other states um
because not everybody's data go would go
to another state if we did enact the
sharing of data which we don't do with
any other states at this moment in time
um it is really kind of we're trying to
be proactive thinking about this for
future use to let individuals know that
in the future it may be shared um but
once again that would only be for those
individuals who received care or
vaccinations in other states um and we
felt as though by um providing that
information they would consent knowing
that they had that um as a possibility
um make their own choice and then if
they later changed their mind after
participating they would be able to
reach out to that other state directly
to request that withdrawal and it would
just be removing the department from the
obligation of having to process that
withdrawal from another state system
that we don't have that access to that's
good 10 minutes um since representative
sh Schmidt has arrived representative
hacken Phillips can sit in for Senator
wetley
sure sorry follow up yes please um I'm
actually really confused by that process
um I I greatly appreciate that after the
initial hear public hearing on this this
in October um we worked together and we
worked together in what I saw is good
faith um at that time I was told that
there needed did not need to be any
change to the statutes in order to do
that because it was consistent with our
existing statutory Authority and it was
consistent with the State Constitution
and therefore I was told that it was
unnecessary for me to file House Bill
1669 in order to ensure that the Privacy
rights of our people are
upheld um so I'm very very confused as
to why when this was moving forward
prior to the introduction and drafting
of my bill that was never communicated
to me and the intention from the
Department I understood was that this
would be included in the administrative
rules and my bill was therefore
unnecessary but would be a belt and
suspenders approach um so that's where
I'm coming from and why I'm so surprised
what I'd like to know is when um these
confusions and questions were communic
ated to the legislature because it
sounds like through this process some
important issues came up which could
have been resolved through House Bill
1669 had we been aware of them so I'd
like to know who was made aware and
when so so just again so I think the
problem we have is a chicken and egg
problem right so we interim studied some
bills with a bill knowing that there was
a rule coming forward and then once we
inter studied the bill the rule went
away that was being proposed
where we're in a kind of a circular
logic kind of problem it seems that
there's more to it though because it
sounds that sounds like there were
issues that that that arose because the
the the statute change was intended
simply to back it up to make sure that
in the future it wasn't changed because
I was told the statute change was not
necessary um but it sounds like new
issues arose and I'm curious as to one
that was communicated okay sorry good
morning um I'm Abby Rogers I'm the
legislative Le to for the division
Public Health Services um I worked on
this legislation with our Bureau of
infectious disease team and wanted to
just make the committee aware that
during the the public hearing on the
bill we had had a conversation um on the
rules had had a conversation with
representative L on her attention on
filing a bill to do uh to make the
changes that we see um we suggested that
we would work with her and meet with her
to to sort of address some of her
concerns maybe in doing uh through rule
but we felt that uh she wanted to
continue with filing her legislation and
moving forward with that we had had some
uh initial discussions and we also had
had asked her to review our language as
well um we worked uh with the house
committee um and uh the bill was changed
in the house committee we also worked in
finance um with the parties on the bill
um and at the end of the day when the
bill got to the Senate I think the the
feeling was in helping Human Services
that we don't currently share
information with other states and this
was really a sort of getting ahead of
yourself sort of situation although very
important for privacy and to rec
recognized article 2B of the
Constitution that it was sort of you
know sort of more than what we do right
now happy always to protect privacy and
look at that in the future but the
Senate the senate committee decided to
um hold it either for further review or
revisit it in the fall um so that's kind
of where we are and that's kind of the
synopsis of our work on
it um yes my further question would be
um um just when that change was made
because as of the middle of April um
we're still moving forward with the
intention to um so the specific language
that I'm concerned about here so that
everybody knows what in the world I'm
talking about that would probably
help if I don't know if you want to look
at the form or if you want to look at
the rules they both have the same
page oop sorry I deleted that part so
let's go into the form and the
conditional approval that is on page 12
of the document the um IIs form that we
had referenced previously um initially
um the department was looking to add a
bullet saying I understand that unless
otherwise indicated on this withdrawal
form the department will notify any
other state territory jurisdiction who
received transmission of immunization
information from the nhis to ensure
deletion of immunization information
sent by the nhis and from the other
state territory jurisdictions IIs and
then it had a check box to notify that
um there is is the 1 2 3 4 fifth bullet
in the acknowledgement that had been
removed uh because that was stating that
it would not otherwise be
withdrawn so my understanding of the
policy was that we weren't going to
share it without the ability to follow
the intention of the legislature in
regards to the withdrawal and I'm trying
to understand when this change in
interpretation of it happened and if
that was communicated to the Senate and
if that's part of why it was inter room
studied or if this was just simply mised
commmunication because quite honestly we
worked on so many things and worked on
so many things together this year that I
understand that you may have thought
that a conversation happened that didn't
because I thought there were
conversations that happened that didn't
because we were all trying to keep up
with the Bill Volume so if it just
simply was an oversight that's one thing
but I'm just curious if that was
communicated to the Senate since it was
not communicated to the house so right
so when we when the bill got to the
Senate we testified on the bill and um
was basically they said that we didn't
think this was ready for prime time and
obviously because we don't the
department doesn't currently share with
other states we assured the committee
members that we would certainly work to
um protect privacy but at this point
they thought that we we don't do it
already and if we did do it then we
could address it but to put an
appropriation in for something that we
don't currently do seemed to be not a
good use of funds during this non-budget
year so they put it in a ter study to
review it in the fall and at that point
I think we felt that we would not be
able to to carry out the rule language
without that funding for the position
and the needed upgrade to the system
that we provided in our testimony so if
there was a lack of communication on
that we we certainly apologize but um
the the way that it worked in the Senate
it wasn't that my understanding is we
did not testify that it would be in rule
is that we were looking at it um and uh
and apologize for any miscommunication
but certainly if we were to share to
other states that I think we would be
happy to make those changes and accept
those Appropriations to have that uh
structure in place to do that but we
don't currently share any information
with other states and that was a
decision that the the Senate HHS made to
put it in interm study to wait so that's
that's my update if I can follow up um
it seems like there's a lot of
discussion that still needs to happen on
this since we're not sharing with any
other states would it make sense to
strike the language and the fifth bullet
point um so that the form is silent on
withdrawing from other states because it
sounds like we're setting a policy here
about not withdrawing um from other
states so to me it seems more
straightforward to strike that language
since we aren't sharing with other
states why are we putting it in our
disclosures at this point would that be
appropriate um I can also find where it
would be in the rules specifically but
it would be the fifth bullet point on
the form on page 12 of conditional
approval so prior in prior to sharing
any information we would enter into anou
with the other state we would be vetting
them we would be reviewing their systems
their processes to make sure that
there's privacy confidentiality and
security um that bullet is placed there
um so that way in the event that the
information is not coming to New
Hampshire for withdrawal it it it just
is looking at who is responsible for
holding that withdrawal that statement
is there so that a person knows that
when they're withdrawing if their
information is in another state they
should contact that State directly that
the withdrawal from another state would
not be performed under New Hampshire
because we don't have that state
Appropriations or the position to
perform that function as you recall for
the legislature there was funding that
would need to be upgrading the um IIs
system that was a New Hampshire specific
enhancement because there's not normally
any transaction log of where a
recipient's information would be going
this was putting the onus of that back
onto the individual who has consented to
share their information and has full
knowledge that their information may be
shared with another state so that way if
they do change their mind at a later
point they can contact that other state
directly because that function would not
be performed by New Hampshire unless
those State Appropriations were
made as a followup sure I just want to
make sure I'm clear on what what you
just said we have a little Catch 22 I
think um where you're saying we don't
currently share any information with any
state but here we're saying that but if
we do in the future it's now the
patient's responsibility to chase it
down um they don't necessarily have to
be chasing it down I think most
individuals know if they've received a
vaccination or medical care in another
state so you know if they are uh you
know residing halftime in Florida they
would just contact the Florida Ias so
it's not a matter of chasing down state
by state by state because that
information would only go to that state
which they received care so that
individual would have that information
that process for New Hampshire to track
down where an individual any individual
who with withdraws that that would be
very expensive to do compared to an an
individual taking the matter into their
own hands because they're maintaining
their own records and the refusal for
the other seat um thank you I thought
that one of the reasons why the New
Hampshire I may exchange the
immunization information with other
states is for the purpose of ensuring
the completeness of the record that's
correct so that seems different than
getting a vaccination in another state
and therefore bringing it into the state
that seems like an entirely different
purpose to me so a complete record would
be pulling if if an individual has
consented to participate in our system
and they've received vacc inations in
Massachusetts the Massachusetts system
does not talk to New Hampshire unless we
enacted Theseus to do that exchange of
information so a you know an individual
who's in our system who's a New
Hampshire resident would have a
massachusett vaccination record but
their address would be New Hampshire so
if they have a New Hampshire residence
and were vaccinated in Massachusetts
that information then could sent be sent
over that what that does is that builds
that person's record to make it more
complete because otherwise the um system
would be missing that information when
they were vaccinated in another state
and that would work uh reciprocally a
followup so um if the purpose of
ensuring the completeness of record is
in terms of vaccination immunizations
received outside the state can we on
page five um item
seven add to the statement of of the
exchanging the information for the
purposes of ensuring completeness of
record um in regards to immunizations
obtained in other states and territories
because otherwise that language is very
very broad if the intention is that it's
only to pull in immunization information
happening outside of New Hampshire that
should be clarified in the rules I'm
sorry I don't know if it's on our page
five sorry s it is I'm sorry it's on
page five of the conditional approval
requests sure um
do you know what letter or
30706 uh number H7 H7 H7 oh
okay thank you so and it's a second line
of seven to add for the purposes of
ensuring the completeness of record of
immunizations received outside of the
and I'm sorry can you please repeat what
you were looking to amend between record
and the period at the end of that
sentence I would insert the phrase of
immunizations received outside of the
Mr chair wouldn't that also exclude any
um immunizations that were received in
the state of New Hampshire then so I'm
I'm worried that that language would be
too
exclusive for instance if you know a
resident moved to Massachusetts and
wanted to include their IM immunization
records to Massachusetts for the
immunizations they received in New
Hampshire if you amended the language to
say only the immunizations received
outside the state of New Hampshire then
folks who used to live in New Hampshire
wouldn't be able to share their
information to the new state if you
excluded that so I'm just a little
concerned Mr chair um thank you for that
if you look at the third sentence in
that which is on the Fifth Line it says
that in the event that the registrant
receives medical treatment that would
have prompted retrieval so that already
covers that case and this already covers
the case of receiving a medical
treatment out of the state so the
language of for the purposes of ensuring
completeness of the record period is a
very very broad statement and if it's
intended to capture immunizations
clarified well I think that that that
was included because it does state that
you know if they're
participating they allow the transfer
immunization from another state into the
IAS so if they were vaccinated out of
the state that would come into the
IAS and if they were receiving medical
care or vaccination in another state it
would go to that other State's IAS so
I'm not I'm not
seeing what you're asking in the
relevance um then can we strike for the
purposes of ensuring completeness of the
record because that to me reads much
broader than the following sentences so
if we ended the first sentence right
parenthesis I don't think it would
change the context of the intention of
what we were doing by striking that I
mean that the purpose is to get a to
have the most complete record for
patient so that they have a Consolidated
record no matter where they received
their vaccinations and that that record
can travel with
them thank you um if that's acceptable
I'll see where else that falls in the
rules because I think that line may be
repeated and I'll pull that up I don't
know if anybody else has any questions
but so let's back up so your request is
on line number seven at the end of um
where it says um information
immunization system and I in Brackets
put a period there and strike for the
purposes of uring complete completeness
of record strike those last 1 2 3 four
five six seven eight words correct and
is and the Department's position on
striking those eight words yes or no it
doesn't matter I think striking it here
yes if there's further revision I I
think we would request to review
whatever revisions were being requested
okay I'm scanning right now to see okay
it's already been OC in here so thank
that Mr chair could I ask what the
concerns are with this with this type of
review of the rules I'm not quite sure
since what's being requested was put an
interim study and the rules reflect that
I'm just trying to understand the
concern sure um um you want to answer
you want me to my concern is that I have
been working with the Department to
resolve numerous questions that have
been raised at the October hearing um in
the purpose of doing that they had moved
towards adopting adopting the language
that I was interested in in that bill
however that is based upon the fact that
we have a lot of data creep right now
with hippo things they can Market to you
based on your medical conditions and I
don't know that that was necessarily
intended making sure that our language
is and tight and concise and that the
per for the purposes of completeness of
the record refers to the individual's
record as opposed to the greater public
health record where we were able to
basically combine all of the state's IIs
systems which would be permitted with
that language um I think is absolutely
critical because we're here looking at
protecting the health of granite Staters
we're not looking to become part of a
large 50 state repository where we're
continually washing our data with other
states because that would be an entirely
different purpose than what the
legislature created the I
for so this protects against that
Creed yes but the agency has said they
don't share that data so we don't
participate in that I guess I'm just
thinking that you're you're you're
stating the house position but then the
Senate stated their position and it does
we have so perhaps the question might be
so again I I think that uh just to be
clear and I'll go to representative
moral in just one second is right now we
have an a request to just strike some
words that are causing represent concern
based on what went on the agencies
agreed to it and said it's okay that
doesn't change the content of what they
were intending to do um so that's where
we're currently standing um but director
Morel has a something he lik to uh thank
you because representative Lon has
indicated there are other places which
have the same or similar language uh
it's the committee could continue this
to the next regular meeting with without
a waiver and uh give time to find out
exactly where the other sports are if
that language is identical and give the
agency a little more time to determine
make a
determination but that's up to the
committee um I've done my search and
that is actually the only time that
phrase appears I just wanted to make
sure we weren't removing it one place
and leaving it
elsewhere
okay okay further discussion
can I can I just represent l so I have
to say I I am not into the weeds of this
at all but what I am concerned about is
it
appears that what representative L was
saying was that as this matter was going
through the legislative process and if
I'm misinterpreting this represent
please correct me but it appears that as
this matter was going through the
legislative process if I understand
resentative lon's uh point is that she
was told by the agency well this really
isn't necessary to deal with this
through legislation we can't handle it
through the administrative process um
and and and we'll do that and then it
turns out that the bill is goes to
interim study in the Senate perhaps for
that same reason because it's you know
something that that the legislature
believes or the Senate believes could be
handled through legislative process and
then when we get the legisl when we get
the regulations they don't address it
and that's if that's true that's a I
mean that's a real concern because it
seems like and I I don't you know lay
this on any particular individual but it
seems like there's been sort of a
misrepresentation to the legislature
about well we'll be able to do this
through the legislative process and then
it's not done and I think if that's if
that's the you know the fact that really
is a concern
thank you for your question I can
address that a bit I think to shed some
light on this so the first time that we
had um discussed with representative Lon
that there she was interested in putting
legislation forward was that the rules
hearing the public hearing for this Rule
and we said oh yeah we're happy to talk
with you about your concern certainly we
take legislator's concerns very
seriously um we uh understood she was
going to file a piece of legislation
which she did
1669 which is which she represented I
think it was the first part of her bill
was filed we met with her in January to
discuss her concerns related to the rule
um looked went over the bill language
and looked at what we might be able you
know to do to accommodate uh concerns we
like to meet with legislators I mean the
whole time we were saying that we don't
currently share information with other
states if we do share with information
with other states you know certainly we
could make these changes um I think we
represented fairly that um we were open
to you know understanding concerns
looking at the you know the the
provision of privacy um the bill we met
with her we we reviewed the language the
bill was filed um we testified at all
the hearings we went to finance in which
Finance put in um some position funding
for positions to update the system at a
cost of $80,000 for a onetime up upgrade
you know taxpayer funds to to make this
change for something that we don't
currently do it's a practice we don't do
if we do do it that would be one thing
but we we don't currently share
information with other states there was
also a I'm sorry but can I just have to
interrupt just for a second so
did so I was understanding that and and
again maybe this is just a
misunderstanding on my part but that
that what representative Leon was told
by HHS was
um your concerns are legitimate concerns
and we will address it in the in the
regulations as opposed to what you seem
to be saying now is no there's no need
to address this in the legislation
because in the regulations because we
don't share information with any other
states anyway so there's no need for
this and those are two I think two very
different things yeah I don't think
there there was I mean from our
perspective and we our B Team met you
know with legislators all the time there
was no misrepresentation on our part
we're happy to work with legislators we
don't currently do the practice if
somebody files a bill and wants to you
know impose something upon our agency
we're going to testify in the bill we're
going to say what we do do what we don't
do what we can do you know we can do it
if there's funding to for the position
and the upgrade but certainly there was
no misrepresentation the Senate um
dispensed with the bill into interim
study I think the Department's position
is here we are talking about this the
the current legislation that was filed
is an interim study meaning in the fall
when the Senate HHS committee meets they
could look at the bill and say oh you
know let's make some changes to this
that will require additional room making
which require us to come back so right
now we would rather wait we're H this is
important issue absolutely but it's not
ready for prime time we want to wait and
see what the Senate decides and the
senate committee if they're additional
changes to the system to the then we're
back here again and so we said well
we'll take it out of the rule we'll come
back and we're happy to address it but
we don't it's not a practice we do if we
do do it we need the position the
upgrade and all of the things but I
think we've ascertained here that we're
you know trying to be transparent and do
what needs to be done it is not
something that we currently do um if we
were to do it there's some further
things that need to be worked out so
apologies on miss any misrepresentation
on that but that was how our team viewed
it collaboratively working and I did
send um the rules to representative land
three or four times for review and you
know at the last minute with the busy
session didn't get any response back on
those so you know just don't want to put
blame but like we're we're just trying
to get it everybody Happy on on what
we're doing but this isn't a practice we
currently do and happy to look into it
for but cently we don't um thank you on
the April 17th copy of the rules it
still included the language about the
withdrawal but moving outside of this
let's look at how we're moving forward
should I expect a budget request for
this position so that we will be
prepared should the department enter
into um any M us so that we then don't
have to do that out of the budget cycle
or will that not be coming in the next
budget cycle we would need to put in
state Appropriations if we were charged
with insuring ing that withdrawal and
doing that work themselves um once again
I think the option that would not cost
New Hampshire any dollar would be for an
individual to be informed of how their
information would be handled they would
have the choice to participate or not
participate and if they chose to
participate they would know that where
they got care or vaccinations they would
have to contact if they chose to
withdraw from that other state you know
for for New Hampshire maybe a person has
permanently moved to Florida and they
want to keep their information in
Florida this is saying the department is
forced to do that withdrawal so we're we
may potentially be withdrawing
information that the person did not want
to remove so I think that we have to
look at this very carefully if who
should bear the the responsibility for
performing that withdrawal is that a
task of the department or would we be
able to throughou have stipulations in
theou that said that you know this other
state would honor a person's request if
they made a request to New Hampshire
maybe they could just accept the New
Hampshire form so I think it's just a
matter of where that responsibility lies
and the dollar amount if you're asking
New Hampshire to be responsible for it
you know there's there's very few people
that do change their mind especially
after you know informed consent where
where they know that they have the right
to say no I don't want my information to
go in because it could go to another
state I think that's those are the
details that we need to work out which
is why you know waiting for any further
rule change makes sense until we have
that interim study so we can have these
full
discussions soes I just suggest you
support the go to the interim study
committee report meeting when it happens
and make sure your voice is heard so the
recommendation for the future
legislature would be known okay thank
you and I'll make sure I'll make sure to
request that I'm notified of when they
meet for the that interim study thank
you so I'd entertain a motion to
conditionally approve of the edits
that's been approved by the agency is
there a motion so moved it's been moved
by representative Leon second to approve
condition approv with the edits that the
agencies agreed to on um rule 23 1994
any further discussion see n all those
in favor signify by saying I I all those
opposed nay the eyes have it the rule is
adopted thank you
ladies next up is the boxing and
wrestling commission we'll take up
23280 uh permits and licenses For
Fighting uh Sports and
competitions so I have no substantive
comments on this role there's only a
need for legislation comment so the
issue is the boxing and wrestling
commission still has fee Authority Under
RSA uh
28513 and r a 28410 where it sets the
promoter permits at $100 for each day
for the event um however the
responsibility for administration of the
licenses and uh was transferred to the
oplc pursuant to HB
279-282 but no changes were made to
28513 and so um we are recommending that
amendments are made to that statute that
would clarify that the commission no
longer has Fe
Authority which is consistent with the
other boards and so this this will just
be something someone needs to pick up
next year to deal with um the statute
because generally we don't set fees
directly in a rule like this we have a
fee schedule that is managed by oplc as
a whole not the board that manages the
event so there'll be future legislation
necessary to clean this up but we still
need the rule to move forward that's
correct so um and were there any minor
edits that were done that we need to
conditionally approve with edit um this
is an amended conditional approval I'm
sorry this was an amended cenal approval
so that's what you would be voting on
great any further discussion on rule uh
23280 seeting down and entertain a
motion to
approve second been mooved by
representative second by represent gr to
approve rule 23280 any further
discussion seeing done all those in
favor signify by saying I I all those
opposed name I have it the rules
approved next up is Rule 23282 ethical
standards so this is similar um 285 for
the boxing and wrestling commission just
does not clearly specify that there are
um Authority for ethics rules um they in
the rule they site to RSA 15a 15b and
RSA 21
G27 so what we think is is that the the
RSA 285 which is for the the commission
needs to be adjusted to include those
citations so that they can have the
authority to make ethics
discussion so uh the i' entertain a
motion to approve uh rule 282 as
written moov by representative Leon
second by representative hacken Phillips
at any further
discussion all those in favor signified
by saying I I as oppose nay and director
moral you'll make a note that the
legislative update so at the end of the
year we have our list of future
bills next up is the Department of
Safety uh talking about the northern
border Alliance program under rule
2447 yes sir um there is one substantive
comment um and that is because the
interor roles expired on May 29th and
you'll see that comment on the top of um
page one of the rule which is page five
of the PDF packet the agency did request
a waiver of the 21 day deadline to file
the final proposal for this proposal a
couple of days before the meeting in May
um they were trying to get these rules
adopted before the interim rules expired
on May uh 29th but the waiver was denied
due to lack of notice like I said they
filed it two days before that main
meeting but um the Jael car may have
some questions about uh the operation of
the grant uh since the Endor rules
expired on May 29th um there's really no
um enforcement but you may have some
questions around that operation of the
grant um there's one other comment
further down on page nine but um that
comment has been resolved I noted that
in the cover memo to the proposal um we
spoke with David Hilt and he let us know
that this grant really isn't competitive
it's first come first served and so
think that the uh qualifications or the
requirements in the rule are are good
enough for the non-competitive nature of
the grant funding but anyway that's the
only issue is that the en rules expired
on May
29th thank you very much so for those of
us that been on the committee you know
when we have expired rules one of the
things we always talk about is fees and
enforcement but in this case there are
no fees and enforcement so there is no
real implication other than they didn't
have rules for a certain period of time
but Captain if you want to say anything
you're welcome or or sir thank you sir
I'll leave the uh the wiser and better
spoken to the two of us to speak unless
he call from
me any discussion on the northern border
Alliance rule
2447 iate a motion to approve don't move
good move by representative Liv second
by representative Lon to approve rule
2447 any further
discussion seeing none all those in
favor signify by saying I I well as
opposed nay the eyes have it rule 2447
is approved moving on to
246 various carnal and amusement rules
uh and I'm also going to ask you to
speak about um the emergency rule that
goes along with this consecutively so
you don't have to come back under other
business so okay so um there are just
two issues to bring to the committee's
attention on um on these rules um it is
an in room Rule and they were put
forward to um to minimize the time
period of expiration the rules expired
on January
21st um so initially when they filed um
they just filed them just without
changes in order to get those rules uh
back into place and um but we did have
some comments on it so they did file a
conditional approval to address those
comments and um as uh the chair
indicated there are uh some um there is
a set of emergency rules that are
different they deal with other various
carnival amusement rules so my
understanding is that the um agency was
bringing those forward in an emergency
basis because they need those in place a
little sooner than they do with the
interim rules but um like I said the
only comments we had are that the rules
good morning attorney Dave hiltz for the
Department of Safety um we're happy to
entertain any specific questions the the
committee has um depending on what the
question is um I have Deputy State Fire
Marshall Mitch Katy um and also Chief
Inspector Briggs Lockwood and myself and
so we're happy to field any questions
that you have in particular so just I'm
GNA talk about the interim rule first um
so again you understand the inter R
expired we need we need a rule in place
because we have county fairs starting up
uh for the summer and we need these kind
of regulations in place to make sure the
safety of our citizens and the emergency
rule piece is strictly that is it you
need it in something in place right now
without public hearing order to deal
with the safety of the citizens for the
summer but you will go through
ultimately rulemaking process to resolve
that that is correct okay so we to talk
about uh so iate a motion to approve I'm
sorry is there any further
discussion Iain a motion to approve
inter room rule
246 I yeah 246
six I'll make the motion if nobody else
is going to make the motion I second
I'll second second by represent of Grove
to proove inimum rule uh
24-6 any further discussion seeing on
all those in favor signified by saying I
I all oppos n guys have it thank you
gentlemen just to clarify that was for
conditional approval I'm sorry just to
clarify was for conditional approval
conditional approval on on number 26
because it's an inter
rule Thank you very much thank you and
there's no action to be taken out of the
emergency rule it's informational
only next up is
2450 uh so for this rule the department
did file a revised amended conditional
approval that addressed all of staff's
comments however this was kept on the
regular agenda because there is an
informational note to the committee at
47.1 a those subparagraphs have
specific numbers for which uh Timber can
be cut and those numbers are found in
the statute however the numbers in this
proposal reflect the new uh excuse me
the amended statute which was SB 514
which will take effect July
1st so as long as the agency does not ad
adopt and make effective these rules
before July 1st they will be fine I have
talked to the agency they have agreed so
I would recommend that the committee do
a conditional approval with the
understanding that these rules will
become effective on or after July 1st
thank you so again to make the committee
clear we passed a law last year and we
also passed a law this year they
Incorporated both laws into the new rule
but obviously the new the one we just
passed doesn't take effect till July 1
so they have a rule for a law we haven't
that's not effective yet so we're asking
the the motion I'm hoping will be that
we conditionally approve understanding
that we hold off implementation of the
rule until July one so that it it can
cover both make move has been moved by
representative Subs conditionally
approved and seconded by representative
grassy any further discussion other than
we passed another law you'll be looking
at this rule again just to let you know
um so any further discussion all those
in favor signify by saying I I all is
opposed nay the eyes have it 2450 is
conditionally
approved next up is uh
2466 uh so the agency did file a
conditional approval request for this
proposal it did address a majority of
the comments from the final proposal
however there are still a few that
remain
uh one of which is a result actually of
the conditional approval uh so the first
comment is on page six of the
conditional approval request text um it
references in paragraph B A scoring
Matrix and then lists 12 requirements
that the Matrix shall have however if
you then look at paragraph C it says
that the score Matrix shall demonstrate
um or it's it's a demonstration I think
of what a scoring Matrix will look like
which isn't exactly a requirement but it
then states that there are four
requirements and assigns points to those
four requirements set points within the
rule so it's kind of unclear about how
the agency is going to assign points to
the other eight requirements that were
in paragraph B and if the four
requirement that do have the set points
if that's going to be a set for all
applications or if if it's just a
demonstration it really shouldn't be in
the rules at all it
should it's not a rule if it's a
demonstration uh the next comment is on
page eight um and this is the one where
the agency changed the language in the
conditional approval previously on the
final proposal they had stated that
municipality
could not enter contracts with related
or Affiliated contractors for materials
labor or Services unless they
demonstrated that the contracts were
fair and competitive on the final
proposal I made a comment asking that
they create more criteria or more
examples of what municipality had to
provide in order to demonstrate that the
contracts were fair and competitive and
then additionally put in the
rules what the process was should there
be a disagreement between the agency and
the municipality on what is fair and
competitive uh what the agency then did
was they simply struck the language that
the municipality need to demonstrate
that the contracts are fair and
competitive so now it just reads that
municipalities cannot enter contracts at
all with related or Affiliated
contractors which potentially could be
fiscal
impact change that they would need a
revised FIS for because they had
previously given a benefit to these
contractors under this a um grant
program and now they are taking that
benefit away so there is a potential
fiscal impact there and there's also a
potential fiscal impact on the
municipalities if they can no longer use
contractors who they are affiliated or
related with they would then have to go
and find other contractors which could
result in a increased or decreased
fiscal impact
um so that is the only two comments I
had on that
proposal thank you um do you want to
speak to what they did sure thank you
very much Chase Hegman uh director of
the division of economic development at
Bea I just want to start by saying the
OS team has been incredibly helpful in
this process so thank you for all your
feedback and input uh and I'll say the
uh the department agrees um with the
with the assessment um as pertains to
section 6 405 B and C uh with the Matrix
concern um I think there's just a little
confusion on what was intended uh in
that language the um criteria the 12
criteria in section B is uh I would
describe more as um uh principles or uh
explanation of the subsequent specific
the four scored categories so I think
the um what the department would propose
would be to effectively truncate that
section into the Matrix um as they as
those um uh principles relate to each
Matrix criteria that are already scored
so effectively moving and I've already
numbered them but the the the numbered
uh criteria would simply be collapsed
into uh what would what is currently
section c within the appropriate uh
Matrix
criteria and to the second comment
around municipalities the second comment
um the the department also agrees uh and
I think it was sort of a circumstance
where the baby was thrown out with the
bath water uh and over correction uh so
we would recommend adding the language
back in where municipalities are able to
have um Affiliated and related
contractors um and we'd work with OS in
the best language for that but our
recommendation would be that the
municipality and developer would have to
demonstrate that the contract that's
engaged in is uh effectively uh meeting
industry standards and best practices uh
and we can work with the with OS on on
what that language would look
like thank you so my concern again on a
municipal piece especially in small
towns you may have a developer who was
also a contracted uh plow operator
during the winter right or or or does
construction work on the side of the
roads you know to do culverts and and
those kind of things in small towns and
the language you presented would say
they could no longer do business and
with that contractor at all if they're
also involved in an invest in h project
as well sure so that's my concern with
the language as I read it so I'd hope
you address that so I think the answer
would be is there any further discussion
around this so I think the answer is to
preliminary object let them go back
correct the problems we've identified in
B and C as well as this municipality
language and they can bring back the the
uh response that we
get I'm make before we make that motion
I want to make sure I'm right on the
preliminary objection is the right
motion um yes that is certainly an
option um that the agency could do to
correct that the other option
potentially would be just to postpone uh
this till the next meeting to allow the
agency to file an amended conditional
approval if they're willing to work on
those issues um it wouldn't need a
waiver as the deadline for the committee
is until July
30th um but if it's going to need some
extensive work a preliminary objection
also would be uh appropriate to allow
them to work through it in a response I
think we'll just postpone it for now if
if everyone's okay I'm move their postp
we'll do the second so a move to
postpone second invite represent Smith
to postpone rule uh 2466 until the next
meeting any further discussion all those
in favor of postponement say I I all
those oppos nay eyes have it it's
postponed until next meeting 2466 next
up is uh 2467 the housing Champion
program uh so once again the agency did
file a conditional approval that
addressed uh a majority of comments on
the final proposal
um these are brand new programs so there
was a lot to work through um and the
agency was able to do that in a short
amount of time as they only filed these
rules with our office in April so they
have definitely been doing a lot of work
on these rules um but there are still a
couple issues remaining with regard to
unclear comments on the way that the
certain sections and paragraphs are
written uh so the first is on page seven
of the conditional approval request text
there's an unclear comment um
on Bea
C3 because the language does not follow
the introductory language in C which
essentially makes it a bit confusing
because the introductory language talks
about
municipalities shall demonstrate the
following but then paragraph three talks
about in order to receive points the
municipality shall provide a copy of
relevant section so that paragraph
should not be a sub paragraph in that
section it really needs to be moved
either incorporated into a different
section or made its own paragraph the
next one is on page 14 another unclear
comment
because the way the paragraph is worded
it says shall meet the definition
outlined in 504 .08 b 2 and
3 that section is the section
immediately above and it's not a
definition it's more of uh conditions
that need to be met in order to receive
these points these scoring points um so
that language needs to be changed uh to
clarify that that's not a definition uh
to avoid
confusion uh the next one is also on
page 14 more toward the bottom uh
paragraph D4 it's unclear as
written because the way it's worded is
whether a project has entered into
public private Partnerships but a
project cannot enter into a partnership
so it's
unclear who the agency actually intended
would be the
one entering into these public private
Partnerships so that needs to be
clarified next is on page 17 there's an
unclear because the agency did not
include a conjunction at the end of the
last subparagraph
and because of the way it's written it's
really could be an and or an or so it's
un usually we can make an inference of
whether it should be an or or an and but
in this particular instance it could be
either so the agency really needs to
clarify which one it actually
intended on page
18 uh another unclear comment uh because
paragraph D it's a it's an incomplete
sentence all it says is bonus points um
and then additionally there are sub
paragraphs under D so it's also lacking
introductory language for those
subparagraphs so that one needs quite a
bit of work page 28 there's another
unclear comment uh because the language
says this rules so it's unclear if the
agency intended to say these rules or
this
Rule and finally on page 34 um this
one's actually an authority legislative
intent comment because the agency after
it Awards these grants they then have to
enter into agreements with the awardees
to lay out the conditions and what the
awarde will do um and under RSA 541
A14 these are technically considered
rules however the committee has taken
VAR positions in the past on these types
of agreements or essentially
contracts um and so it's really up to
the committee whether or not they would
want these written out as rules or if
they would um simply allow the agency to
reference them as agreements um
additionally with regard to this rule
set specifically there's also additional
oversight on these agreements because
the awards will be uh approved by the
governor and the executive Council so
there's also that additional oversight
when it comes to these agreements um but
once again this is one where you could
either issue a preliminary objection and
allow the agency to file a response to
address these unclear or if the agency
is willing to work with us and file an
amended conditional approval you could
also postpone this one uh without a
waiver uh to the next meeting to allow
the agency to do that I'm going to
recommend we postpone till next meeting
give them time to work with the uh with
the staff to clear up all the unclear
comments and uh and go forward but
before we make that motion um there's a
a question I just want to make sure that
you're going to be able to address all
that before we before we meet again
because there's a lot of stuff there I
agree um and I appreciate um the staff
pointing it out and I will say that in
their comments they also made
recommendations that we agree with so
there are suggestions in there as to
what the change would be and I think
with the exception of maybe one it's a
pretty clear pivot uh but there was some
language um previously um adjusted that
uh I think needed some more
clarification and discussion as well um
so one one point of clarification I
think just from the agency agency's
benefit we have a statutory requirement
to have these rules and the previous
rules approved by actually July 1 not
July 30th so I don't know if there's a
possibility to have any kind of
retroactive nature to the rules or how
that impacts our requirements as no we
we're just going to have to recognize
the fact that you have a deadline you're
not going to meet it and legislator's by
a vote as said this committee said we
understand that okay
so so with that if if the chair allows
I'll make a motion to postpone uh been
motion to postpone is there a second
second by representative Leon all in
favor of postponement signify by saying
I oppose nay guys have it we postpone
till the next meeting thank you
gentlemen very
much next up is the board of
registration of funeral directors and
ERS yes um so these rules are on um
applications for apprentice and bommer
licenses um the interim rule was filed
to minimize the time period of the rules
expiration the rules expired on May 1st
um it was initially filed without any uh
changes made but there were a lot of
problems with the rules and that there
were some conflicts uh with some recent
statutory amendments so um the board did
file the conditional approval and that
pretty much re resolved all the issues
there's some minor editorial comments um
towards the end and um my discussion
with the oplc indicated that they're
willing to make those changes so um
again the um only issue is that them
that the rules expired on May 1st um
there are some fees mentioned but if you
recall um the PLC rules were adopted
last August so um that issue is
oplc so our obvious question is expired
rule has been any enforcement or any uh
fees that are governed by this rule
that's expired that uh we need that the
agency needs to take care of good
morning Shantel wheeler office of
professional licenser and certification
um I have can you yes pull the
microphone closer if you
will is that better wait a little bit
yeah I've confirmed with the um board
that there have not been any Apprentice
applications for PR and balers that have
been processed great thank you further
discussion by the committee see on
entertain a motion and conditionally
approve with the
edits moved and second by represent
second by representative hackins
Phillips to conditionally approve with
edits uh 24-4 any further discussion
seeing on all those in favor signify by
saying I I I'll oppose nay the eyes have
it the rules adopted um we have an
objection response from the board of
natural scientists yes sir U these are
on the soil 300 rules uh the proposal
was conditionally approved at the May
meeting and the board's conditional
approval response made some changes that
were not included in its request and so
that um caused the approval to convert
to a preliminary OB objection the board
has filed an objection response as well
as a revised objection response which is
um highly unusual um it sounds like the
board only meets quarterly so um it
sounds like they filed that for
convenience since that board only meets
quarterly um typically an agency will
ask the committee for a revised
objection response and then the
committee will approve it but it's up to
the committee whether or not you want to
approve that the revised objection
response you do have that linked and it
makes um some substantive changes that
were not in response to our comments but
um on the objection response itself
there is one unclear comment that you'll
see on the bottom of page 11
and that's because the language is it's
slightly arguable whether or not that's
substantive we feel like it can be
argued either way it pretty much does
the same thing that it did it's just
rewarded um anyway we recommend that the
committee approve the objection response
and again it's up to the committee
whether or not you want to you know
discuss the revised objection response
or not if you want to approve it Dr Mora
um it's always been the history of the
committee that uh an agency cannot Act
uh on something that has not occurred
since the objection response since
the committee has not yet entertained a
revised objection then there can't be a
revised objection response um I even
remember one instance where Dees had a
rulle that they definitely needed in
place to get Federal funding and they
had a deadline of the day of the jail
car meeting they got a preliminary
objection they took it back and came
back to the committee and got the
approval on it it's the same thing they
you can't do a second step until you've
done the first
step right so again just to be clear as
everyone's clear what what happened was
we objected to this we gave them a list
of things that we objected to they in
their first response responded to a list
of things we gave them and then said oh
by the way we also want these other
things and then gave us a revised
objection response the problem is you
can't do the second thing because we
didn't tell them to look at it as part
of the rule process so um so I I'm going
to say that the only thing that's going
to be put in front of us today is the
objection response the first that their
response to us and I'd ask staff
comments on the objection response um is
there anything that's still pending
after their
response uh no there is like I said
there's one unclear on the bottom of
page 11 um the rest of the comments that
are made are just notes to you letting
you know that um that those sections
that those places were amended but all
those were in response to OS comments
the only one is on the on that one page
at the bottom of page 11 of your PDF and
like I said um Mike and I both thought
that it's arguable whether or not this
is substantive we we think it says the
same thing but just in a different way
so um we have no other comments on this
objection
response does the board have any
comments it's Tina Kelly um program
um specialist office of professional
lure certification the reason that we
submitted both the objection response
and um the revised objection response is
that the wrong um amended conditional
approval request was submitted to jail
car previously and I had the board come
in and we we had planned out a way to
move forward to get them to where they
needed to be it in Alliance with the
correct
um Revis amended conditional approval
response and so the board meets
quarterly they came in for a special
meeting and I felt no through no fault
of their own um that we would just
follow the plan that was laid out to get
these to where they needed to be in in
compliance with the or in alignment with
the amended conditional approval
response that was submitted by the
office
understand that we can't do that because
of 541 a right so you you were
responding to things we didn't talk
about and and we didn't bring up as an
objection and then you put them into the
rule again or into the rule and by our
processes we can't do that so we can we
can we can deal with the revised
objection I mean the objection response
that you gave and we can approve that
but we can't have you add things after
that we didn't we didn't address so a
point of clarification yeah does the
board need to remet and revote on this
you would need to reopen rulemaking if
I'm not if I'm not mistaken to deal with
all those changes you made that were in
response to our our objection that's the
that's correct if the objection response
is approved by the committee then uh new
R making would need to be started to do
changes any further discussion I
entertain a motion and conditionally
approve the objection
response it's been moved by
representative grassy second by uh
representative schmith they approve the
conditionally approve with that it's the
uh objection response any further
discussion Mr chair I think um maybe the
agency has additional questions do
confused on the process so we approving
the
response new R making has to be started
to do the other things that the board
wants not
revise I
actually it's a choice of the board
whether they want to go through new rul
making to implement the changes they
made inputed in the revised objection
response excuse me keep that again okay
uh you put new things in the revised
objection response the board did uh they
can't do them if they wish to implement
those they can do it through another rul
making okay but for the uh purposes of
today you just need to file an adoption
of the objection response
okay forther discussion all those in
favor of conditional approval the
objection response uh with edits
signified by saying I iose nay I have it
the objection response is adopted
thanks where are
we other business Board of Nursing Dr
Mora
thank you um first I would note
there is an error at least on the online
agenda um the first it says discussion
item
13984 the next two say discussion item
13985 uh the first of those is a
rejection letter that should not have a
document number as no document number
has been issued um so the uh earlier
this year the board filed an an
emergency rule
regarding uh nursing 30105 and nursing
30502 um Unfortunately they did not
base uh the emergency rule on the most
recent version of the rules it was a
prior version um so the committee asked
him last month or the month before as
actually petitioned the board to uh
repeal that emergency rule the board did
that on um May 24th same day they filed
a new emergency rule
um
and the problem with this one is in
13052 uh the board thought the entire
section was currently in effect and they
uh reopt it it with Amendment they
struck some stuff they inserted some new
language unfortunately almost all of
well most of
13052 had already expired uh there were
a couple of subclauses and some
introductory language that was still in
effect uh because of this there are
u rules that were in effect that are no
longer in effect uh under the emergency
Rule and there were Provisions that uh
were amended that could not be amended
because they did not exist
anymore because of this lack of clarity
with the emergency rule I discussed with
represent Maguire and with uh director
alukonis and I decided that a receip
would not be issued to the agency and a
document number would not be granted um
what the agency could do at this point
is repeal this emergency rule
and file a new one and we would be happy
to sit down with the agency to assist
them uh to make sure the right uh right
version of
file thank you again there's no action
for us to take on this it's
informational only yeah oops I'm sorry I
do uh the agency uh told me and I made a
mistake on the letter that went to them
today um it says reopt with the entirety
of Ed 30502 that should have been
nursing
30502 thank you um next and for the
Health and Human Services the emergency
rule
comment um no we have uh examined it and
uh found no uh basis for the committee
to enter a petition uh does the
committee wish to enter a petition
regarding the uh
most recent filing from the Board of
Nursing great all right any other
business come before us idate a motion
to uh wait finish sure what I'm going to
say yet now I'll say whatever I want
right so I'm good I got a motion um so
we don't need our conditional meeting um
so I a motion to to do away with our
conditional meeting it moved seconded
all fa doing conditional meeting signifi
by saying
i n great Dr Mor anything else you need
to take
up I would just remind the committee
that this is the last meeting on a
Friday for this year the subsequent
meetings July through December will be
on the third Thursday of the
month also we are moving down the hall
we are not going to be in 219 of the
annex we'll be in 220 where agriculture
agriculture out there now yeah well I
mean I know you're playing musical here
all right motion don't move move second
by represent L on all those in favor
signify by saying I iose name eyes have